Do you remember what you were wearing the day you got your driver's license? Do
you remember the first place you drove to or who was in the car with you? Do
you remember the price of gas or was it a warm day, a cold day, sunny, rainy?
All of these things that you can remember are about the day you got your
driver's license constitute what we call episodic memory. Now, episodic memory
is memory for autobiograhical events. Here, we're looking at information
remember that is both temporal as well as contextual. Meaning when and where
the even occurred. Another type of memory that was related to but different
from episodic memories are semantic memories. Semantic are memories about
general fact or general knowledge. So, for example, an episodic memory might be
remembering your sixteenth birthday party. The people who were there and your
favorite song that was playing on the radio. Semantic memories can be things
such as general knowledge, like things you've learned in school. Such as E
equals MC squared. But we're also going to talk about a different type of
memory and that's declarative memory. And we're going to go back to Lauren for
that.